what's going on guys welcome back to get
culture explained my name is rob and in
this video
we're doing the rumor roundup which is a
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that are circulating
around the internet with regards to
comic book movies and tv shows and
everything although now that i think
about it i feel like we should just make
individual videos on this kind of stuff
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section so i'm sure you
guys much like me
were very saddened by the fact that we
did not get the spiderman no way home
trailer i don't know what led me to
believe we were gonna get it outside of
the fact that i got swept up in the
internet saying
it's tom holland's birthday he usually
does stuff like this on his birthday so
he'll do it again this year too but we
didn't get it i was actually sitting
around waiting to make a reaction video
for the trailer
that never came that was disappointing
but have no fear all you spider-man fans
according to sony executive sanford
panitch spider-man no way home
is actually going to set up a shared
universe between marvel studios
and sony so obviously sony's not letting
go of their cash cow but the important
thing about this is that it sets the
stage for crossovers between these two
things
most likely spider-man will remain a
sony property we'll probably continue
seeing him in the marvel cinematic
universe but we'll also see more
spider-man stuff coming out of sony so
how does that work how do you get
spider-man and the mcu while in sony at
the same time
if they're all completely different
universes here's the answer for you web
warriors web warriors was a comic book
line that was published by marvel comics
that was really really really really
cool
the whole idea behind this is that if
you guys recall spider-verse you had a
whole bunch of different versions of
spider-man and spider-woman who are
teaming up against a threat called the
inheritors we didn't see that in
spider-man into the spider-verse with
miles morales instead we actually had a
much better plot that movie was amazing
but the whole idea behind the web
warriors is that when they came together
to fight a common threat they came to
the realization there's all kinds of
threats around the multiverse so we're
gonna have a loose knit team we're gonna
call ourselves the web warriors and
we're gonna travel around the multiverse
fighting various foes now does that mean
that i think tom holland and miles
morales and miguel o'hara are all going
to team up in the spider-man into the
spider-verse 2
probably not but it would be cool to see
it take place what i think this is most
likely leading to is that assault is
going to be
one cohesive universe that you're going
to see all the various villains movies
that are going to be made by sony and
they're going to cross over into the mcu
it's not going to be some magical portal
or it's not going to be doctor strange
opening a bridge to another reality
that leads to them coming here it's
simply going to be that they all exist
in like san francisco or they're all in
like new jersey instead of new york but
whatever the case is going to be there's
going to be a clear line of delineation
between the sony properties and the
marvel cinematic universe properties
but for you and me as the moviegoer
we're not going to see a difference
they're all basically going to be
teaming up or fighting each other or
something along those lines
in the end it works out for us and isn't
that really the most important thing
that we enjoy the movie when we go see
it in the theaters i'm sure marvel and
sony would agree
now another big piece of news here is
that we found out more about the
eternals from the merchandise than we
did from the trailer which
really isn't that surprising because the
trailer didn't hardly give us anything
but the merchandising that's coming out
for the eternals film
actually establishes the idea that the
eternals operate on titan and basically
monitor humanity keeping humanity safe
from whatever threats may happen to be
out there why they didn't protect
humanity from thanos i don't really know
the ongoing theory is that they actually
wiped their minds now one of the other
theories going on here is that the
eternals are not actually human instead
the eternals are robots the biggest
problem with this theory it doesn't
really answer the question of why it is
overpopulation on titan would actually
be a problem if they're robots they
can't really procreate i mean i guess
they can insofar as they can create more
of themselves but they don't procreate
in the traditional sense and so this
theory kind of gets knocked out of the
park by the very idea that the eternals
struggle with overpopulation the whole
motivation behind thanos was that titan
was becoming overpopulated that there
were simply not enough resources to
support
that many number of people and so the
result of this is that he was kind of
exiled when he was talking about
effectively culling the herd
and then ultimately titan collapsed
anyway now my writing theory on here in
terms of how we connect the idea that
eternals
operate on titan safeguarding humanity
and yet somehow are operating on earth
at the same time
it's not necessarily going with the
comic books in the sense that some civil
war happened in the early days one group
of eternals defected went to titan the
other stayed on earth instead i think
it's a lot simpler than that i think the
eternals
really are more or less human beings and
the eternals move to titan in order to
safeguard humanity from other threats
after all if they existed on earth
how likely would they be to know those
threats were actually coming it'd be
more effective to be on a planet that's
close to earth but not exactly
on earth that way they could intercept
those threats before they got to earth
but the important thing here is that if
thanos was really telling the truth and
titan basically succumbed to
overpopulation it would stand to reason
that some of those individuals actually
bailed on titan if the planet was no
longer habitable
what's the point of staying there and so
in turn they said okay well if our job
is to safeguard humanity then let's just
go to earth we might as well be close to
the people we're supposed to be
protecting and there's not much here we
can do anyway because the place is
basically derelict now the real question
to ask is
if titan ended up succumbing to
overpopulation when did that happen did
it happen when humanity was still in a
primitive state it would certainly
explain why a lot of those eternal
showed up on earth did it happen at some
point
after that what would also explain why
the eternals were on earth if the
eternals lived on titan there's nothing
to say they didn't travel
to earth and then teach humanity how to
basically progress itself and then
leave and go back to titan that may very
well be the case it's one of these
things we basically came to visit said
hey here's some technology have fun
and then went back to titan just kind of
keep an eye on things but no matter how
you slice it we do get this really cool
bit of information there it gives us a
better perspective
of why thanos did what he did it gives
us a much better perspective in terms of
how thanos is involved with the eternals
beyond the idea that he was an eternal
living on titan with a deviant gene and
titan somehow collapsed due to
overpopulation
it's one of those cool little concepts
not a lot of information there
but it is cool to see nonetheless now
our next bit of news here is something
that i'm very excited about but i feel
like not everybody is
the screenwriter for doctor trains 2 has
basically confirmed the movie
is going to be very dark it's going to
be the darkest of the movies that we've
seen so far i love this idea because it
means a lot of my hopes for the
characters we're gonna see are actually
gonna come to fruition if i'm being
honest i think the darkness of the film
is really gonna stem more from what's
going on
in the multiverse as opposed to like
darker versions of doctor strange or
anything like that i imagine that some
of the stuff that we'll see in the what
if series will
actually end up appearing in doctor
strange multiverse of madness
as just alternate realities after all we
know from the previews of loki and the
time variance authority
that every possibility that can't exist
essentially does exist and that new
timelines come into existence because
somebody goes back into the past and
changes things and so if a possibility
exists and there's a universe for it
there has to be a universe for every
single what if story that we're going to
see in the what if series but focusing
back on doctor strange i like this idea
we'll probably see
nightmare we'll probably end up seeing
dormammu it still begs the question if
the realm of dormammu is a splinter
realm
or if it's a realm that inhabits all
these different demonic entities that
we're aware of
and is ruled by dormammu but regardless
it looks like it's going to be a dark
film does this mean a lot of people are
going to die i kind of think so
but it's one of these things where you
kind of look at it and it's like okay i
mean how dark could it really be
because avengers in game was pretty dark
but i don't really think it's going to
be anything in line with like earth x
or marvel's those stories were
unnecessarily dark if you guys don't
know what those are check the
description i haven't covered over
comics explained but it's a cool idea to
see that the doctor strange film is not
shying away
from the darkness of what can be a
chaotic multiverse and instead
is leaning into it but again it's disney
we know it'll be pg-13
it's not going to be rated r so we know
it's not going to be obnoxiously dark
we're not going to see like bloodshed
cursing and people dying all the time
but i
am curious to see exactly how dark this
movie's going to be
speaking of alternate realities the
marvel what if series officially has a
release date
august 6 2021 and i am very excited to
see what kind of possibilities we get
not a whole lot to speak on here but it
does lead us into our next topic which
is that we got a little bit of a tease
on what one of the thor episodes is
going to be apparently in the what if
series we're going to get an episode
where thor
never finds his humility instead he
comes to earth and basically just
parties for those of you guys who read
comics all the time you should know this
sounds pretty familiar there's actually
a what if story where the beyonder
basically an omnipotent being who
kidnapped all the heroes and villains
that made them all fight each other
actually ended up turning an entire
reality into the 80s and just partied
all the time that's all he did
now for what we can tell in this little
bit of a solicitation here that
apparently thor never finding his
humility and then just having this great
big huge party
is ultimately going to culminate in the
destruction of presumably the world
or possibly even the universe itself we
don't exactly know how this is going to
play out
just kind of a quick little synopsis we
got on one of the episodes but
regardless
i'm excited to see a version of thor
that never stops partying
so we already finished recording our
video hits the reason why i look
different but this piece of news dropped
and i felt compelled to cover it
according to the illuminati the mafia
cinematic universe is going to give us
an episode of what if that takes place
in age of ultron and it's going to focus
on black widow if i'm a betting man it's
actually going to be an
adaptation of the what if comic from age
of ultron that came out for marvel as
part of the age of ultron event let's
talk about what it for a second back in
the day marvel released the what if
stories as just one shots alternate
reality stories where things just
happened a little bit different based on
existing events
spider-man never lost the venom symbiote
punisher's family was never killed in
central park then marvel got the idea of
creating what-if stories based on
existing major popular events age of
ultron is a really good example of that
in this what if story focusing on age of
ultron basically thor ended up facing
off against the world serpent the
problem is that thor died before he
could defeat the world serpent because
of the main age of ultron's story
wolverine kept messing with time and
ultimately broke it because of this the
world serpent basically killed all the
avengers and what was left of the
superheroes just kind of existed
underground a little ragtag pockets of
just trying to survive
they ultimately got the idea to go to dr
doom's fortress and take his time
platform and go back in time to save the
life of thor but because time was broken
they couldn't time travel this
ultimately led to the realization that
somebody needed to lift the hammer of
thor to take on the role of thor to
defeat the frost giants who had invaded
earth as well as defeat the world
serpent
ultimately nick fury not samuel jackson
white guy nick fury
ended up grabbing black widow along with
a handful of the remaining superheroes
sam wilson
falcon silver sable so on and so forth
they traveled over to the world serpent
black widow ended up lifting up mjolnir
defeated the world serpent and the day
was saved i think they're going to adapt
that into the animated series now if i'm
being honest with you guys i don't think
they're going to adapt the comic as a
one-to-one ratio meaning we're going to
see the world serpent the frost giants
and all that kind of stuff that's a
little too far-fetched if i'm a betting
man
what i think is going to happen is that
ultron basically won he may have left
facsimiles of himself behind and that
was more or less it the important thing
here is that we're going to see black
widow most likely left mjolnir because
in the original age of ultron movie if
you recall when everybody was taking
turns lifting thor's hammer the offer
came to natasha romanoff and she said
no i don't really need to prove anything
and that was it this would be a really
cool throwback to that particular event
where she actually ends up picking up
the hammer of thor
and she's proven to be worthy because
i'm gonna be honest with you guys i
think natasha
could actually lift it with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching
we will catch you all later peace